we're on the ocoee river right where are
we at
these are rafting people ocoee water
sports they came to the show last night
and then they just hit us up and asked
us if we wanted to go rafting you know
water is really it's god's blood baby
yeah i used to be a professional a white
water rafter for about three years
before stand-up comedy so i'm going to
lead us down
read this bible up there is it that
dangerous huh
[Music]
everything could be just right
[Applause]
[Music]
these shades of color
blend with each other i wish i could be
the leaves on the trees
it's [ __ ] beautiful
that group baptism is cheaper
that's how i
it was fire it was a thousand percent
fire though
hey man man it's so much fun save on a
hotel room or you plug in here dude we
would never do that but i would i
appreciate it
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one